Hey, what's going on? It's Bill Burr and It's time for the Thursday afternoon.
Just before Friday.
Monday morning podcast and ahhh,
just whisper head while check it and od Ya.
Okay.
It's like fucking seven 15 in the morning. My wife's downstairs still sleeping.
Um, you know what's hilarious?
Fucking Versie texts me right at like six 10 in the morning.
He goes, I was just at a great diner, ordered eggs over medium.
They came eggs over easy and then rights. Unreal.
So then I wrote back, I text back, right?
I was laying in bed and my fucking phone goes off, right?
So I wake up and that's what, that's what I read, right?
So I just text him back and I go,
they didn't care Paul. Right?
And then he writes t techs back,
how are you up at this hour animal?
And then I text back, I go out,
cause some guy on the east coast keeps texting me.
How come when you put your fucking phone on vibrate?
I guess it's the vibrating sound. You think it's going to be silent.
I gotta find this. Then go into your settings. Oh fuck you.
You know, my goal for 2016 is, is to just not go into my settings.
What are they going to come up with? The fucking robot that does that for you,
right? Just goes into your set. Why you don't want that?
Then you lose total control.
That's like sign over power of attorney at least fucking dopes that I know for
the guys and I'd have a a money manager and you know,
I haven't paid a bill in years and they just have some guy writing checks on
their account, signing their fucking name or there you go.
Is a good move financially, what could you do?
Want to lick a stamp a couple of times a week,
you're going to just hand over all your finances.
Everything you ever fucking work for to some fucking jerk off,
can't do that shit. You can not do that.
Anytime you're in a position of a money manager,
you cannot do it because there's no way.
You're not making more money than that fucking guy. If he was,
he'd have his own money manager, right?
So all he's gonna do is see you making more money than him.
And then he's handling all the money that eventually he's going to be like,
yeah, you know your, I think I'm entitled to more.
Maybe I'm going to go to McDonald's today on his dime.
And he writes a check [inaudible] for four bucks, right?
Eight fucking chows down any weights.
See if just guy pays attention. See if you fucking notices
that $4 checked in McDonald's was written this month,
that then stay waited another month. Played safe place safe. I mean,
but fucking with jail time here, play it safe, right? You go two, three months.
He doesn't fucking notice I gay. My kid's got a birthday coming up.
Let's see if I dip it in. I go to fucking toys r us.
Let's see if you notice this. Let's see if he notices.
I'd go down there and get the fucking Millennium Falcon and all this star wars
shit for my son and for my daughter. I'll get her the fucking kitty, Kerry.
I'll fucking easy bake a whatever the fuck you get upright, right?
A little bright LP, right?
Not Linda did by talking a little broad here, right?
So you fucking go down and you do that, right? There's fucking Wa whatever,
150 bucks over the count does. He notice, doesn't fucking notice, right.
Does Not fucking notice. And then you know you to Spec it.
It just keeps opening and opening and then the guy can't stop,
can't fucking stop himself. He's taken so much fucking money.
He starts donating some of it to charity.
He's fucking taking his friends out and don't worry, it's on me, right?
That's all the guilt.
He knows it's coming as he sits between his 2000 thread count fucking sheets at
night,
he's just laying there knowing at some point that door is going to be kicked in.
You know, he's just going to hear out the door and then he's going to be like,
did I just dream that? Boom, it's going to come open there.
He's going to bake like Jerry London Garden fucking a
and Fargo trying to go out that bathroom window and that it is going to grab him
as he goes, Eh, Eh, faced out on the fucking bed,
right? And natives, what's going to happen? All right. They'd get them.
And they'd go to jail and then what the fuck are you going to do?
And then you got to take this car to court.
He's already blown all the fucking cash.
Or you know what she could do?
You could make out a check to the fucking gas company every fucking month.
He could do that. You know, you could sit down in front of the TV, you know,
watching a little bit of the news.
She could do that and just not open yourself up to that shit. I mean,
that's what she could do. Oh, I'm on my fucking stump today.
I just yelled, my wife's going to give me shit. But you know,
when you're in a relationship,
there's ups and downs in the relationships and there's times when you give a
shit what that person thinks about you. And then there's times when you don't.
Seven in the morning on a Thursday when I'm a little grumpy,
I don't give a fuck. She'll be mad through breakfast.
I just don't understand why you have to yell that early in the morning.
I don't understand. I know you don't understand.
I know all day long. You don't understand.
She a fucking Goddamn ammo. That's the lady's emo.
I don't understand why you don't just do everything that I want at the moment
that I want you to do it.
I don't understand that I live with somebody else that has a different schedule
than I do. I don't understand. Um,
anyways, Jesus Christ. I uh, you know,
I've watched the last three Celtic games in a row believer in and not,
I can't remember the last time I watched three Celtic games,
regular season games in a row.
Not even when we bought the NBA title in 2007,
2008, whatever the fuck it was right that season.
I never watched three games in a row. I just didn't,
I hadn't watched them and fucking ever, I was totally turned off by the NBA.
I was convinced that it was fixed. I said it for years. I said, at this game,
the fucking league is fixed.
And then they ended up finding a ref that was fixing games that fuck the
Sacramento Kings out of a playoff series,
the western conference finals, if I remember correctly.
And the Lakers went on to the finals and won a championship.
That guy is admitted that he fixed that series.
The Lakers still have that banner right now, and I didn't give a shit.
I was sitting there, I felt vindicated going, hey look,
this is what I've been saying.
I told you it was fixed and you know what these hoop had said to me.
That's right. I call them who? Peds. You know what they said? They got all,
it's just one guy. It's just one fucking guy.
Hilarious. Fucking hilarious. You know what I mean?
I'd love to see a guy do that on like the view or the talk one of those shows,
you know with all the lady sitting there,
when they bring up domestic violence going over fucking blah, blah, blah.
Women are beaten every year. Just be like, why? And I was just like, you know,
it's like 6% of guys,
other 94% of us are crushing it.
As far as not hitting women. I'd love to see you do that. You know what?
You be called? A fucking sexist. A goddamn animal. It would probably,
if they could affect your bottom line.
Cause it's never ed about educating people when they make ignorant statements,
it's about destroying their ability to earn a living,
which is great. You know what I mean?
Cause I'm sure that helps that person's hateful heart, you know,
to have the group that they have an issue with,
take away his paycheck every fuck at wake or her paycheck,
then I'm sure they go, oh now I get it.
Now I guess I should be less racist. You know like they,
they do that when someone gets busted for being a racist. Right.
They get busted for fucking being a racist. Right.
And rather than trying to educate them,
they just kick them out on the fucking street. What does,
I'm not saying you'd all hold somebody accountable.
I'm not saying you don't sit down and tell.
You should try to fucking educate them.
I guess there's gotta be some sort of a fine though, right?
Get a couple of weeks suspension. I don't know.
How do you really change in a racist?
I don't know you. I make, well you know what,
white guys can't jump, but they make those little things that, you know,
they stick on the bottom of your sneakers to give you the quick twitch lease.
They showed that on the back of the, you know, the comic books.
Maybe they could make that for like racist people,
you know, a better yet. You know, not better yet, but
I have alleged we switch it up public. How about nags? You know,
if you with somebody who's just a whiner or they nag a,
that just a fucking pain in the ass.
It's just something you can put on the bottom. This shoe,
give him a little spring in this step, you know, get the endorphins movement.
You know what I mean? Get him to walk around the block.
Maybe see a couple of butterflies, you know, chill the fuck out.
Maybe you could do that. I have no idea.
Do you see those two surfers in Australia invented that thing that can vacuum up
the ocean? It really can't,
but it can get rid of a lot of litter.
I don't know how many you'd need to fucking end the swirl.
We got going out there in the fucking Pacific Ocean.
But it was a really cool idea and it was um, I have a dental,
he safe murmur for marine life and all of that type of shit.
And it actually gave me hope for our ability to, uh,
continue being here for any sort of foreseeable future.
And then I was just like, you know, what's going to happen?
Is there a,
the game that they're going to have to play to get that thing to a national
fucking level,
international level that everybody would actually use it,
the sea of corporate and political red tape that you would have to go through
and the amount of ownership that you're going to have to give up,
probably 100%,
um,
to actually make that fucking thing happen
is probably the chances of them actually using that fucking thing is probably
zero fucking percent. That's what's going to fucking happen.
You know what I mean? Hey, is it thing that could possibly solve the problem?
Where's the thing? You know, it's funny,
as you vacuum up the fucking litter out of the ocean and then where do you put
it?
You know?
Well, yeah. Then you put it in the ground and what about the worms?
Then the birds can eat it than the cats have nothing to eat.
That dogs have nothing to chase. You know,
certain groups of people have nothing to eat right.
Then we have nobody to fight. Eh, then fuck it. A,
our military goes down the jail. It's a fucking, it's a, it's a,
it's a slippery slope. You start vacuum up the ocean. You know,
I was thinking the other day, you know,
when the world population got out of control is when Shit couldn't be made out
of natural shit anymore. You know,
like if you look at kids' toys
and back in like the forties and fifties,
if you go on Ebay and look at those creepy fucking toys played by now,
dead kids,
kids that are now grown up, gotten divorce you. Oh Jesus,
I the fucking clouds hanging over me today.
This is what happens if somebody texted me before I want to fucking wake up.
I'm grumpy back then.
If you look at those creepy as fucking toys that looks slightly haunted,
you know what I mean? They made out of wood, metal, the cars,
even like the tires who made out of rubber, there was all all natural shit.
So at the end of the day, if you fucking threw those things out,
even if you throw them into the fucking ocean, they don't belong in there.
The end of the day, what do you got? You got a little bit of metal,
a little bit of wood, right? It's going to break down.
It's going to be fine. I'm not seeing the throat fucking, you know,
old dead kids toys into the ocean. That's not what I'm saying. Yeah,
but I'm saying or whatever.
You take it down to the dump and all of that Shit's going to biodegrade. Right?
It was, you know, once we went into the plastics, fuck it over,
cause there was so many goddamn whining kids,
they had more whining kids than they had fucking trees and rubber.
That comes from my tree, right? Jess?
What makes that little lowland Danky can climb that rubber tree plan.
A fucking, it's a tree and a plant
doesn't make any sense. It's the Bruce Jenner of fucking trees.
It's hybrid. It's got a leg on either side of the fence.
Um, let me look this shit up. Oh, you get to listen to bill type here.
Just what makes that little lowland think he can climb that rubber tree.
Plant rubber tree plant.
Maybe they just put plants in there so it would Ryan with everyone knows that it
can't climb a rubber tree plant.
Okay.
All right. Images. Well that looks like a fucking plant to me.
Robert Tree plant. Why? What is that?
Any of them say rubber tree plan on it. Robert Tree plant.
You know what? My apologies to Frank Sinatra. Whoever wrote that fucking song.
Robert Tree plant be the first to view this product.
You can get one for 50 bucks. Don't. I'm telling you,
if you fucking had a bunch of those things,
if you had a bunch of Robert Tree plants, right,
and you just grew them in a greenhouse outside your house,
all your neighbors would think that you would fucking, you know,
dealing weed and all you would deal with,
with just making yourself your own homemade radio ty. Yes.
Okay.
Can you still buy studded tires? Do you remember those fucking things?
They had nails in a, you know,
you can run over children with them and they blame the kids studded tires.
There you go. Studied tires for Studley snow tires,
images for studded tires are good that you get a little traction.
Then of course some rednecks got to do it with the spikes coming out.
Yeah.
I love those rednecks.
Who Like wrote La Roland Cole that fucking dopes like that make it some sort of
statement and they always turn it on and they blow the black smoke into a Prius.
Yeah. So he's a guy who's like pumping their fist.
MMM [inaudible]
I dunno. It's one of my favorite things. What was I talking about? Yeah.
You gotta go back to make the kids toys. If I was elected president,
if I was running for office, right.
I, I, that's what I would say. I would go up there.
I would completely ignore Donald Trump. And whenever he talked to me,
I would just look at the crowd and be like,
is he puckering his lips or his lips still? Puckered I can't look at him.
He looks, he looks like an old angry fish who didn't achieve his dreams.
And now we pick it on all the younger fish, sorry.
And his hair is the color of a goldfish.
Um,
I would just say listen,
but we need to do is we need to get the population down to where we can make
children's toys out of wood, metal and rubber again.
Do you understand me? We've got to stop vaccinating people for polio.
We've got to let the measles come back. We gotta we gotta burn off the hurt.
Okay.
I said we need to do so we can once again make toys,
but a wood, metal and rubber. Same thing with cars.
And I don't give a fuck about safety. No more crumple zones.
All right. Go back to the old days.
I'm gonna stick you in fucking model t's, you know,
driving around in a Goddamn toaster. That's what's going to happen.
And then you whip around the corner, you flip the fucking thing over,
and that's it for you. Right? And you biodegrade.
And so does the car,
cause it's gotta to be no more growth or mourns and preservatives or really that
shit in the fucking food. Oh yeah. People are gonna Starve.
Goddamn right. They are. They're gonna fucking star.
Right.
But they're going to biodegrade.
Okay.
And they will create,
will throw them all in the same fucking ditch and they will create a fossil fuel
that we can use to gather in the future.
Okay.
What kind of octane you think that would be? Is that the right word?
You know, human beings turns into a fossil fuel. Do you think we'd be in 87
okay.
91 or 93 whatever the fuck that means. Is that just a purification process?
You know, it's funny.
There's actually somebody who's not in that industry that actually could explain
it. That's the kind of person you do not want to be in a car with for any long,
like I don't, I can't want it. What the fuck?
I'm trying to say long specific time,
but didn't sound right in my fucking head and I still said it a long period of
time.
Yeah.
That fucking guy who just knows a little bit about everything,
but he's still fucking in that fucking one bedroom apartment.
You know that guy still in that same apartment.
He's been there for 13 fucking years and that's not a subject on the planet that
she could fucking bring up yet that cont has not got his bag of gold.
Why is that? I'll tell you why. If you,
you're the town of fucking person that no one wants to drive across town within
a fucking car.
Do you think somebody wants to spend eight hours a day in a board room with you?
They don't. They're going to bury you in that sea of cubicles, right?
They're going to use you as a litmus test to see who the fuck is tough enough to
get to the next level.
I'll tell you think that Susie Q down there has got this stuff for maybe a
corner office. I know what we'll do. We'll stick them right next to Burt,
who fucking knows something about everything right,
but can't even clean the sleep out of his fucking,
I have him sticking his head over a cubicle everyday with this stale,
not quite bad, but not quite fresh breath.
Listening to our conversations on the phone. You know
Dandy. What are you doing this weekend? Let's get brunch.
I'm dying to go to low. Liz Bees, they have the best French toast.
Then he pops his fucking head over the wall.
Actually it's French toast was not created in France. Little known fact.
Okay,
well she could fucking handle that.
She gets the corner office day after fucking day. It's literally,
it's gotten to the point she can't have an orgasm because she just keeps hearing
his fucking voice in her head. You know,
a boyfriend thinks she's fucking around on him.
Her whole fucking life is falling apart. Bitch. She says new age woman, right?
She's willed herself not to have a period she's going for that fucking corner
office.
[inaudible]
you know something, if you're sitting there right now, go,
what the fuck is this guy talking about? I'm not talking about anything.
I have a,
a moral obligation to talk for a half an hour every fucking Thursday.
God Damn. And I'm only 20 minutes in.
I was woken up before I wanted to wake up and uh, you know, I'm a little grumpy
by the way. My new fucking Bible, uh,
my new fucking religion is Mario Batali's a cookbook.
I made the uh, chicken. How does hunter style,
which I had never heard of.
It was absolutely fucking delicious and I messed it up a little bit too,
when it was still fucking delicious. Could use a little more salt.
And I had my heat on a little bit high,
but I took the chicken off early and I didn't overcook it. Thank God.
Cause the lovely Nia came and she goes, I think it's done. Go.
You think it's done? She goes, yeah, she goes, cut into it. I go,
I hate cutting into it. I don't want to cut into it cause if it's not done,
then I'm letting all the fucking juices out and it dries up. She goes,
I think it's done. I said, all right. I could've brown it a little more,
get a little more of a golden color, but other than that,
it was fucking delicious. What's in it you want to add? You want,
you might've not have asked. You know what? Let me hit pause. I'll read a fully,
hang on.
Okay.
All right. I'm back. Okay. Yeah. Chicken hunters style. All right.
He says,
chicken cacciatore seemed to be a subset for every mediocre chicken dish ever
served to me at our restaurants in restaurants in the seventies and eighties.
I love these talking shit right out of the right out of the gate saying
everybody else is fucked up this dish. But I'm not, um,
anything with a mushroom or an onion in it. Qualified for the title in my world.
Chicken. Cacciatore is a simple braise that depends on a lot of quality,
a lot on the quality of the bird itself, but blah, blah, blah, blah, blah.
So I'm clear. You gotta stop staring at me. It's going to happen.
We're going to go to the place you want to go to. Alright?
You already did number one.
You already did number two and I gave you a big can of food with that extra shit
you liked on top. All right, I have the podcast to do. I have an obligation.
Don't yawn in the middle of this.
Where would you be without me? Where would you be without humans?
You know what you'd be? You'd still be a wolf right now.
Right now you'd be eyeballing me. Is that thing weak? Can I go for its throat,
Cleo and a different set of circumstances? You'd fucking eat me.
Do you realize that? Huh? I never met a dog.
All right. All right. All right. I've never met a dog that just fuck it.
You're not a fucking little chihuahua. What are you doing?
How are you? I you're claiming me. Is that what the dog was per says?
You don't get down off the couch. Don't lean into me.
Okay.
I'm gonna Relax. God Damn it. I fucking loved that dog anyways. Clearly.
Um, yeah, so I made it this week came out fucking great. Uh,
the name of Mario Batali's book,
which I highly fucking recommend is a Molto Italiano 327 simple Italian recipes
to cook at home. And uh, let me tell you something right now.
Don't let the words simple fool you. All right?
He keeps fucking, I gotta learn how to do this.
What is this fucking thing he keeps saying?
What's that thing where you put the fucking meat in water like overnight begins
with a B. I forget what the fuck it is. He keeps bringing that shit up.
It's driving me nuts cause I can't figure out what the f hang on a second.
Hang on a second. I'll find it here. Cleo. Stop looking at me like that.
I love how you, cause you can't,
you just think you're just going to stare at me.
Um, okay.
Where is it? Where is it? Oh,
for fuck sakes. Whatever.
You guys know what I'm talking about.
You fucking incident an old school way of like Luis to try to preserve the meat.
But then people found out that it actually added flavor to it and he keeps
sending me to like page three 76 to learn how to fucking do this shit.
Brining
brining was originally used as a means of preserving meats and other foods.
Since the advent of refrigeration,
such preserving techniques have become unnecessary,
but brining has become popular again as a means of increasing the succulents of
meat or bird cuts, that lack of fat or great flavor.
So I got to learn how to fucking do that. Isn't that great, Cleo?
Like I didn't have enough on my plate. Speaking of what, you know,
what an exciting thing I'm going to go, go do today.
I'm going to get my luggage repaired.
I got this fucking pigeon toed wheel that's been fucking the bane of my
existence as I go through every fucking airport in this country. Um,
I can only carry the luggage on the right side if I'm on the left side.
And that thing is that that fucked up wheel is leading the charge. Um,
it's over and it's going to affect my mood and I'm going to be rude to people
and, uh, I'm finally going to get it fixed before I start another year.
I'm out on the road. Um, oh, by the way,
the Patrice O'Neil event is coming up. Uh,
the benefit is coming up in, uh, Jesus Christ in a couple of weeks.
Are you kidding me? Are you kidding?
Um,
it's going to be on January the 26th.
Now I'm getting into town before then.
Wouldn't it be nice if all freckles maybe did a couple of warm up dates in the
tristate area? Uh, look for an,
an announcement on those shows in the next week or so. Um,
and I'll be working with an old friend of mine, uh, Al Del Benny,
who I started off with a long time ago and he's coming in all the way from
Australia. Um,
we all started out together with the late great Patrice O'Neil and last year
when I was working Sydney, Australia,
I reconnected with them and we were telling all these hilarious stories about
Patrice and how much we missed him. And he said, man, I would love to come back.
I go, you'd fly all the way in from Sydney, Australia.
And he goes in a fucking heartbeat. That all right.
That's what Patrice meant to all of us. So he came all the way back and, um,
we're going to be doing some shows together to help him, uh,
pay for his trip and then we're going to do the benefit on Tuesday nights should
be a great time. Um,
which is one of the good things that's actually come out of this tragedy,
this fucking awfulness is that a, you know,
we all get to get together once a year, um, and do a good thing.
So before it gets sad, I'm going to move on. Um,
why did we go here? Yeah.
So I've watched like three fucking Celtic games in a row and I'm already
watching the Bruins games. It's like we're,
I feel like I'm still living in Boston right now. It's kind of Nice. You know,
the games come on at like four, four 30 out here. I tape them.
I start watching them at like six. I can get the game done in about 90 minutes.
I can still go out and do my spots. It's great.
So I actually know some of the Celtics names. Now.
We've got a guy a say a Thomas, no relation point. God Jae Crowder.
I like, what the fuck's the other guys? They, uh,
whenever I look at his name, I can't, I can't fucking pronounce it. Kelly.
Oh, Nina. Whatever. That fucking, I can never fucking,
I'm about to see his goddamn name. I Dunno. Evidently. Uh,
Tommy Heinsohn thinks he's one of the best big men passing in the game.
Kelly Olynyk. There you go.
Okay.
I had to like walk away from it. So we lost a Brooklyn,
we beat Brooklyn. And then last night we fucking had the game,
the whole fucking game and playing the Pistons and then they just kept chipping
away at it. I mean,
I don't know shit about the Celtics other than they score like 30 to 37 in the
first quarter every night. And then, you know, you're like,
I literally texted Virginia, I'm like the Celtics, it'll lighten it up,
you know, shooting some high percentage in the next quarter.
They just shit the bed.
They always say that about basketball to gave a rugs game of runs.
Oh yeah. Be sure it isn't fixed.
And I'd shaven points to keep the fucking crowd interested cause if you blow
them out in the first quarter that people each going to turn the channel.
I Dunno. So whatever. Then this fucking kid ran Reggie Jackson.
No relation. So old. I have these fucking kids that coming around.
They get the same names of the greats that I watched when I was a kid. Uh,
Reggie Jackson, Jesus Christ, kids got ice water in his veins. He did that game.
I don't know anything about him, but you know what's killing me is the pistons,
they're back. They got mixed filthy and McNasty again,
except it's the white version.
They had this fucking beard and white dude going out there. Right.
This guy used up five fouls in about six minutes and they kept them in for the
whole fucking game. He never filed out.
They had him and then they got this other big white dude who looks like the
fucking one of the bad guys. All areas.
Ehrsson elite solver, dude.
You tell me that guy doesn't look like that guy from the James Bond movie metal
mouth that had the, the uh, the metal in his mouth.
Very a very clever name. Um,
you had him at a, who's the other guy?
Aaron bades white.
Mick filthy and white McNasty.
Now for people who didn't watch the Celtics pissed as rivalry,
don't know that reference. That was a bill Laimbeer who I guess was a white guy.
I guess now it's all white. McPhillips the McNasty um,
Bill and bear and uh, the other guy who actually liked
Rick Mahorn does that right? Mic Round Horn. That's right. And uh, what's his,
they will fucking, you know, Morn was just a tough motherfucker.
Bill lamp beer was a piece of shit. That guy was a piece of shit.
But I gotta give it up to that guy at the top of the key.
He fucking hit that shot every God damn time. But other than that,
he was just a piece of shit.
And I remember watching the 30 for 30 on the bad boys in Detroit, and he goes,
you know, we used to try and play a mind game. He's trying to play mind games.
He act like he was out there playing chess. It's just like bill,
you would take in guys knees out. He would throw in elbows to the head.
That's not a head game.
That's just punching somebody in the face when they're looking up,
trying to get a rebound. It's not a head game in that, that deep.
Um,
two favorite things was when Larry Bird punched him in the fucking face
as land barrow. He at the biggest whiny look on his face.
He was like a giant Danny Ainge. And when, uh,
chief Robert Parish just gave him, like, he gave him like a,
he punched him with like, his forearms, gave him like this overhead, like, uh,
he was like, uh, when the UFC guys do like the fucking ground and pound,
except it was the inside of his forearm and he was standing behind them and was
so fucking great that he was on the ground covering up like a little girl.
And he was such a piece of shit. The refs didn't see it.
They knew what happened, but they didn't call anything was fucking tremendous.
But whatever. Anyways, they got these two guys now. Um,
uh, Aaron Bains and Ehrsson,
Les Sova, whatever the fuck their names are. Uh, just,
I dunno that it was more about the banes guy.
I'm judging these guys on one fucking, I'm sure they'd good players,
but I'm judging them on one fucking night, but a, what's his, but I don't know.
I thought, I thought that dude, Reggie Jackson looked fucking great. Um,
and then on the other nights, I want you to the fucking Bruins. It's great.
Even though we fucking can't get a run going lost to the capitals again.
Fucking cuts. Um, whatever.
I'm going to keep watching cause I have a true fan. Clean. Relax.
I'm almost done yet. How much time I got left? Oh, 32 minutes.
32 minutes. All right. So that's uh, that's about it. I,
I did my contractually obligated fucking blabbering by the way.
I, it's actually been raining out here in la, which has been tremendous. Um,
God knows we need, it's like the first sustained, we like two days of like,
we're rained for like half the day, like pouring, which is tremendous.
And they always give, you know,
La people shit because they freak out when it rains. It's like,
well we live in a desert. And then secondly, people just go lay down drive.
It's just, it's fucking rain. Well, what happens is,
is when it doesn't rain for a long time,
what happens is on the roads,
all the fucking shit from the cars, you know,
oil, antifreeze, transmission, fluid, brake fluid,
all that shit that leaks.
It just builds up okay on the ground. And then when the water lands,
it becomes like the soup. So I'm not saying it's like snow,
but it's a little worse than east coast because I used to flip out when I was
out here. Like these fucking people are acting like it's a blizzard out here.
It's just rain. Just fucking go. But uh, it is a little bit, yeah,
it's a little bit of both. They drive like pussies out here and uh,
the rain is a little more slippery. Uh, Jesus Christ on the worst.
Um, all right. That's it.
That's the podcast for this fucking are the Thursday afternoon podcasts.
I just checked in on.
I just thought just checking in to see how your week's going.
I hope it's going good. I hope you know what?
I hope you have a wonderful dog in your life like I do right now.
That's just sitting staring at me cause it has an inability to talk.
So what it does is it walks over and it sits down like a foot away from me when
it isn't itching itself and it just stares at me.
Cleo, he want to go outside.
Get off. Huh? Cleo. See if we get to talk.
Cleo, do you cleo?
Cleo, what are you getting Mike? Frank, come on,
get out. Get Out. Get Out. You going to do it here? Sit.
It just fell on her face. Glio get off. Oh, what are you doing?
You just fucked with my my up. That right. She won't do it. Try One last time.
Cleo. Oh, she just had the luncheon today. Alright,
that's it. I got, I got, I got to take this fucking thing out.
I'll talk to you guys later. Enjoy the, the um, the flashback,
the back of the day. Podcast a shit. She fuck with the volume. That's it.
Uh, Kevin. Nice weekend. Fuck you.
All right. There's a couple of advertising things that I forgot to read here.
So let me open it up my email. Oh, here we go. Trunk Club,
everybody. Holy Shit. 2016 is going to be a game changer.
You're fresh stat stat the year off,
right where we're in the right pants. The right the right shirt.
Trunk Club is here to handle your wardrobe so you can focus on what matters.
Trunk Club takes the hassle.
Man Out of shopping by finding the best clothes for you and your style.
You'll look like 1 million bucks and we'll always have the perfect clothes for
the thesis. Oh my God,
that's so springtime@trunkclub.com slash bar you answer simple questions about
your style preferences and size and are assigned an expert stylist to stylist.
We'll hand pick clothes from the best premium brand brands.
Just approve of what you like and send back what you don't and just like that at
trunk full of fucking clothes comes to your doorstep filled with a pick clothes
that are perfect for you. Sorry it's getting hot here in the car. Try them on.
Keep what you like and easily return what you don't in their prepaid trunk.
Trunk Club is the subscription service.
You only pay for the clothes you keep from your trunk. No hidden charges,
just great clothes. It's a brand new year full of possibilities.
With Trunk Club,
you'll start off the year looking great and clothes picked just for you.
If you didn't hear that the first 15 times get started today and Trunk Club will
style you for free. Plus free shipping both ways.
You only pay for the clothes that you keep. We got it to take advantage.
Go to trunk club.com/ [inaudible] that's trunk club.com/. Berg. All right,
zip recruiter. Um, as a business owner,
your company's only as good as the people you hire.
Posting jobs in one place isn't enough to find quality candidates these days.
Short staffing leaves little time to post the dozens of job sites. Jesus Christ.
What do we do? Well,
you can post to a thousand plus job sites with one single clip.
Click where at zip recruiter be instantly matched over candidate to candidates
from over 6 million resumes. Plus Watch brand new candidates roll in every day.
And ZipRecruiter's easy to use interface within 24 hours.
Zip recruiter has been used by over 400,000 businesses. Um,
today you can try ZipRecruiter for free. Go to ziprecruiter.com/bird that's
ziprecruiter.com/borough one more time, ziprecruiter.com/. Burn. All right,
listen, now the throwback stories this year, uh,
this week for Thursday are going to be classic Rosebowl stories. You know,
j law had the one about him with a barnick being a teddy bear and all that shit.
Hope you enjoy him and I'll talk to you on Monday. Have a nice weekend. Yukon
[inaudible].
He's the son of the government man on a pillar.
I was bombed with God on my hands and have all the signs of it.
All right.
Well I went to another Rosebowl everybody and I think I'm just now starting to
recover. First of all, what a fucking game. I,
I'm just like, the rose bowls are already unbelievable,
but to add that whole playoff fucking atmosphere too,
it was just insane. And uh,
this year me and all the guys we got over there,
we was so fucking organized this year we,
we had, we had fucking everything.
We had fucking everything, food, booze,
other stuff.
Jason Lai had put on a display of tailgate cooking that it was,
he had a career year. That's what we were saying. He had a breakout.
It was just fucking, and it was the best breakfast sandwich I ever had.
Then he made these ribs that were unbelievable.
Then we went to the game and at the end of the game it was freezing out by then
and we was smart as how smart we were.
We brought up quarter wood and one of the grills we turned into just like a fire
pit and everybody else who was waiting for the traffic,
every Balis people were coming and gathering around our little fire going,
you guys are smart. Oh this is really smart.
What I left out is we brought everything except fire.
We forgot to bring a lighter.
They were bringing the grills and they were bringing the charcoal.
So I assumed that they were going to bring the fucking lighter and I brought the
Lennar every year. So I guess that one was on me. I don't know what.
But other than that it was a, uh,
it was another amazing time. And um,
okay.
It was fucking hilarious. We basically, we get into the game,
got in on time cause it's a fucking playoff game. Right.
And there was so many people getting tickets that I couldn't get four together.
I got two and two. So we were like couple rows,
two or three rows in front of a nick and lie ahead. And we're sitting there,
you know, and I'm pretty, I'm not as bad as I was last year, but I was fucking,
uh, I was feeling no plane. All right.
I was definitely more than dehydrated at that point.
And all of a sudden I see security walking out with Jason Lawhead and there's
no,
Joe Botnick in Jay is looking at him over at me with his hands,
like up like what the fuck? And he's yelling at me and I'm going,
Jay Jay way they take it and I'm in like, I'm in the middle of this fucking row.
There's like 30 people on one side, 30 on the other, this old school stadium,
right. Total fucking fire hazard. Right. I'm like, Jake, where you go Jay,
and he's fucking yell at me. I can't hear.
And that just whisking them out so fast.
There's nothing I could do other than I just keep going with j j
plus looking at me like, what the fuck turns out?
Uh, I don't know. Bart. Nick was outside.
He was in the stadium but outside the stands,
I guess he had sat down or something and nodded off the,
when he came to,
there was like fucking 20 cops surrounding him cause t such a big guy.
I thought they were like, they were like, what if this guy starts swinging?
We're fucked, and they went down there and they told I,
they looked at his ticket and they went up to get Jason.
That's what they did and they said, we gotta he's been overserved,
which is the understatement for all of us for 2015 and a law had,
to his credit,
the only thing he did better than cooking was talk his way out of that.
He just kept going, I'll come. I look at a Guy [inaudible], he's a teddy bear.
He said, he's not, he's not hurting anybody.
He's going to go off days and sit down. He's going to be able to use it.
He just kept saying,
he's a teddy bear and Joe was just looking at the teddy bear.
They fucking let him in fucking liar.
The politician gets into his seat,
he sits in his seat and then promptly fucking passes out and some lady behind
lye head goes, hey, you're going to have to get him outta here.
And Jay just looked at her and said, hey, hey, come on.
[inaudible] he's not hurting anyway. He's a teddy bear. Okay, listen.
And she fucking Judd back at him. And Jay was just like, listen,
if I tell you what, if you will just watch the game,
you're not even going to see them. Okay. I mean,
I can wake them up if you want me to. I'll wake them up.
I don't think you're gonna like it, but I can't wake them up.
And people just started laughing and it was over.
And we had a wonderful time seeing two of the top college football programs play
each other, say hell of a game through two and a half quarters. And then, uh,
Oregon.
I gotta give a shout out to the ducks just for shutting up the FSU band that I
didn't have to hear that, that fucking Tomahawk Chop again. And I do,
I fucking called it that band knows three songs,
they know the school's song, they play something else and then everything else,
de la, la, la, la,
the whole fucking game. And I'm
okay.
It was, I mean, I don't know, I would like to see a little bit of a closer game,
but uh, I really enjoyed, uh, the fact that they shut that band up.
Nothing against FSU.
I actually really liked the Seminoles and I've always loved that program.
But um, somewhere along the line that Tom oc chopped just fucking,
it would be like if at the Red Sox, like, you know,
awful it is when they sing sweet Caroline,
just imagine if they did that between every fucking ending.
I mean you'd want to kill yourself, right?
If you want any sort of a human being. And that includes being a red sox fan,
cause I want to jump off the fucking monster when I hear that fucking song just
once and you're looking around and fucking women putting their head on the
fucking guy's shoulder. It's just like, ah, I don't know.
Well maybe, I don't know. Maybe I should be a little more positive about stuff.
Shit like that. I have no idea. Um,
the rose bowl, everybody, I'll do it. I'll tell you right now,
if you're going to pick a beer to start the day with,
I'm telling you Miller high life, ah, in, in the,
you got to get it in the bottle. Oh my God, the sun's just coming up.
We've got this seven Oh four in the fucking morning. It was freezing cold out.
There was a frost on the fairways. I'm telling you guys,
you got to fucking do this. Okay? You don't got to go to the Rose Bowl.
Fucking pick something that you and all yet dumb guy friends are you and all
your dumb fucking women friends.
Just you gotta have that one thing you'd do every year. You gotta have that.
I don't give a fuck what kind of responsibility you gotta.
You gotta have that one fucking thing. So anyways, we got there.
The frost was on the fucking fairways. I actually said this year when I got out,
I said, hey guys, guys gotta go take this in right here.
This is the best part of the tailgate.
It's the beginning and this time tomorrow, you're going to wish that,
that this fucking moment, actually no,
cause you'd be too hung over three days later when you get all the poison out of
your system, you're going to be fucking longing for that feeling.
Do we get out of that truck ear to ear, fucking grins
and then Bart,
it's got this thing that he yells out to everybody to the entire parking lot.
Um, I don't want to say what it is cause he yells at so fucking loud.
And so far nobody's ever found our fucking tailgate,
which has been great because we make a spectacle of ourselves. Um,
you got to do it. So anyways, the Rosebowl let's, let's read this thing here.
Uh, Dear Billy football, uh, love the podcast.
He knew his special was nothing short of amazing. Thank you very much.
Thank you everybody who has been watching it,
rewatching it and telling other people to watch my new special you people are
all the same. I'm sorry. Jesus Christ. I'm sorry you feel that way. Ah,
Jesus Bill. Um, I really appreciate it because, uh,
this one has been getting the best response and uh, you know,
that makes me look good with the people I'm in business with over there and
Netflix. So, uh, you guys did me a solid. I really appreciate it. All right.
Um, anyways. Anyways, here we go. Anyway,
I had a question about your Rosebowl outing last weekend.
The game itself was great from that opening Oregon drive when Marietta thought
that's how you say his name. I didn't, there's two Heisman trophy winners.
I don't even know their fucking names.
I was so busy this year and I was so hammered.
I even had a fucking program. I had no idea, uh,
of pitched it to the guy who somersaulted to the one yard line f and later
completed the two point conversion. All that was great in the beginning, um,
to famous James flopping around fumbling for an Oregon touchdown late in the
third. It was just a great game and I was thoroughly jealous. You were there.
You're obviously an Oregon ducks fan. Uh, my question is,
can you share with us a couple of your favorite moments from this year's
Rosebowl. I kind kinda did that, but there's probably some more.
I'm sure you had. You in the goon squad.
You roll around with a gun in some funny situations or conflicts.
Ps, I saw law ahead and part Nick and Boston for the all things comedy tour.
They were great guys and had the pleasure of sitting with part niquet at the bar
while Jay crushed in on stage. Cool dudes.
I would love to drink and smoke stokes with you all some time.
Happy New Year and go fuck yourself. You Apron wearing cont.
Ah, that was a good one. You bounced it. Um,
I think I've already told uh, the stores. Yeah,
throw on the football or the food. I mean, I don't know.
I was pretty sober but I was kind of a consistent level,
like blacked out. Um,
I dunno what, what was it this year?
Just the whole fucking thing.
You know what's cool is watching a father with his two sons and he was playing
automatic QB, it teaching his kid the quarterback to get inside, you know,
inside the receiver and a watching the big brother,
older brother fucking rivalry reminded me when I was a kid,
I sat there smiling, drinking a beer, probably look like a pedophile,
but I was actually thinking nothing but clean stuff.
Everybody looks like a pedophile now. Um, I dunno,
I gotta be honest with you the whole fucking days, God damn blur.
I remember most of the game I did,
I passed out a little bit in the first quarter for about a minute and a half
football time and then the second quarter for about a minute and a half. But uh,
other than that, you know, I crushed waters for the rest of the fucking game.
I didn't have any beers afterwards cause I had to drive and that's by then,
you know, we stayed there till like eight 30, nine o'clock at night.
So by then I haven't drank in like eight hours. So I'm actually so sober,
I'm fucking hung over at that point.
What have we done so far?
[inaudible] phase time
[inaudible] I'll be on the west zoos squad.
What's your role this year? And I did not drink. I did not drink.
And I know there's a lot of you who are disappointed that I didn't drink because
you want me to fill up your life with the hilarious story of me making an ass of
myself once again to kick off a new year. Well, God damn it, I didn't,
but I stood around and I watched it enough other people, fuck it. Do it.
And I still have plenty of stories and I got the brain cells to remember them.
Um, it's a fucking awesome game.
It was Wisconsin versus TCU at uh,
I was like, most people were like, who the fuck is TCU?
And then you look in the program. Let me go grab the Rosebowl program.
Hang on one second. Just you guys just sit tight. Just relaxes.
I walk across the road
trying to find the Rosebowl program. Oh, here it is. Look at this.
I found it. I really need to get it.
I want an assistant on this podcast. All right, I'm back.
So here's the Rose Bowl program and basically
the rose bowl this year, if you were going to turn it into an awful,
you're going to turn it into an awful made for TV movie. This was a,
I guess it was a story about respect. All right.
In that people barely respect Wisconsin because they never go to the rose bowl.
I can't remember the last time they won the big 10 championship,
but they finally won it. They won it. And uh,
they beat the likes of, uh, let's, let's see. Let's, let's see who they'd beat.
All right, let's go through their whole fucking season here really quickly.
Stop Rolling your eyes. You fucking Cami. Non Sports Fan cunt. All right.
Start off the year they beat UNL v.
These are the cupcake games early in the end. And they beat San Jose State,
Arizona State. There's a pack 10 team, Austin p. Who is that?
Somebody whose name did they play? One guy. Uh, then they beat Michigan state,
then they beat Minnesota. They beat Ohio state, right? Big 10 Iowa. Purdue.
You've heard of these teams, Indiana, Michigan. One of those teams,
they actually lost two, but I went by too quickly. Northwestern, you know,
they played some fucking teams.
T see you on the other hand, didn't play shit.
It's okay. She down there and outside of Dallas, Texas, Texas,
Christian, O g, she's university.
And you wonder why no one gives a fuck about the mountain west program.
I want you to write me and tell me just exactly. Okay. Oregon state too.
That's PAC 10. That's Tennessee tech. This is their undefeated season.
They beat Oregon State, Tennessee tech, Baylor, SMU,
Colorado state, Wyoming, BYU, air force,
UNL, V, Utah, San Diego State,
New Mexico. That was their undefeated season.
And they're sitting there scratching the top of their fucking heads,
wondering why they're that people are questioning their record.
All right, so here's the deal. I'm sitting there going, all right,
I like this big 10 even though the big 10 isn't what it used to be considering,
they went, oh, and five on fucking New Year's Day. Um,
who doesn't like an underdog? So I'm going, well, fuck it man.
I'm going to root for TCU even though they have Christian. Oh,
she's in the middle of their fucking name, which, you know what that means?
They automatically think they're better than everybody else.
And Jesus loves us best, despite the fact that they're preaching,
that everybody needs to be more understanding like Jesus.
Somehow they miss the irony of the fact that they feel like they're the chosen
ones. Like all stupid fucking religions do. Right?
Jewish people think they are the chosen ones.
Christians think they're the chosen ones. Muslim thinks that the, you know what?
You guys are all a bunch of douchebags. All right. None of you matter.
That's why there's so many of us. If we were special,
they'd only be like nine of us.
Once there's 7 billion of anything I may worry about. We're not special anymore.
Okay. Do you understand that? We're like socks. You know,
actually some poor people can afford socks.
The socks is still important to some people. You know,
I don't want to fuck them. Say it's a, they
got a fucking pay in their bonnet about how nobody's respecting them.
So I'm sitting there, this is before I talked to anybody from TCU. I just saw,
alright, you know, purple and black does a decent colors. Man,
I liked those Wisconsin. I'm looking at all these fatties from Wisconsin,
you know, walking around just horrible,
horrible shape. I think when, you know,
when Europeans look in America and they think of of the fat fucks, you know,
I think, I don't know.
I think they send away for a Wisconsin broach university brochure every year.
I don't know what, because Jesus Christ, those were some healthy fucking people.
All right?
Evidently the recession has not hit Wisconsin yet because those people have
plenty of money for extra food. So anyway,
so I'm sitting there and we start to walk into the game, right?
Me and three of my buddies were all good,
and I don't name names on this fucking thing.
We go to walk into this goddamn thing and I start looking around after, oh,
after a wonderful tailgate. We really did it up this year.
Plenty of booze. And which I did not partake in.
I brought a 12 pack of water. Go ahead, email me, call me a fag.
I don't give a fuck. I feel great. You fucking cuts. Look at,
I'm still defensive about it, you know, at least I'm one of those, those, those,
I'm not a preachy sober person. I'm not going like, you know,
why do you do that? What are you, what are you running from?
I know why you're doing it. Cause it's fucking fun.
And I'd still be doing it if my head didn't get three times the size of its
usual enormous size.
You know my head when I'm not boozing looks like one of the moons of Jupiter.
Okay. I don't,
I don't need to continue adding to it, you know,
and then have it be like Pluto and then scientists can fucking debate on whether
or not it's a fucking planet. All right. The fucking fucking fucking,
there you go. See I needed the help there. The F word for me is,
is my, my uh, uh, what are those things?
The HGH of my fucking comedy. All right.
And I'll continue to use it and I don't give a shit cause they're not banned in
my industry. Um, anyways, so what was I saying? Right.
So we had a great tailgate. We show up. I became in the backway this,
this this year. All right. We parked right along the fence.
We right near the clubhouse on the golf course and then you can,
I could literally see one of the lights, you know that lights up the stadium,
so we were right there. There was no way we were getting lost this year.
Actually brought a frying pan, brought some eggs. We had burgers,
hotdogs, steak. We had shit to throw in the omelets. Cheese,
everything you want. We had a spatula. We brought tongs. We had napkins.
We had a fucking garbage bag.
We had a grill bag of charcoal, four bags of fucking ice. A cool.
We had every tick.
We had fucking corn chips. We had salsa. We had two bottles, a
Ho jar, a fucking pickles catch up. We had everything we had.
We had, we had real forks and steak knives for the stakes.
We had everything except for a fucking table.
Yeah.
God, next year is going to be the per every year two bottles of crown royal.
A case of fucking beer. We will ready to go.
We even had orange juice for the fucking eggs.
We will ready to go and we forgot a God damn table.
This is one of the ways we start the day off with one of the best fucking
omelettes.
You ever going to have new year's Day sitting on a golf course on a sunny day,
no one, the rest of the Goddamn country,
Snowden screaming at some ticket agent that they got to get back to Albuquerque
before they yak. You know, shits the bed, right?
You forgot a God damn table, which isn't bad when you eat an almond,
but when you're eating a fucking steak that's an inch and a half thick that's
been cooked at best rare,
it's supposed to be medium rare. Okay? It was,
it was just medium rare.
What happens is you got it on a paper plate and as you use pressure to cut into
that, it creases in the middle and you see this puddle of,
of, of grease. It just starts coming.
It comes close to your balls and then it goes away.
Just like the tide coming in and you sitting there going, you know,
I really should. I just drip the rest of this grease down into the grass,
kill a couple of lady bugs and then continue on with the eating process.
But it tastes so fucking good. You Go, you know what?
I think I can do it one more time and then you do it.
What happens if fucking rolls right off onto your jeans and you haven't noticed?
I don't give a fuck.
Yeah.
What you spill, where you spell it.
You could have your arms outstretched if you spill any sort of liquid.
It not only does it land in your Crotch,
it lands right at the head of your Dick.
So it always looks like you pissed your pants. So that's what I look like.
I had grease on the front of my pants. Um,
I mean while I'm sitting here watching all these Wisconsin fans walking around
and they got these candy striped fucking overalls,
they look like Richard Simmons shorts.
If you fucking mugged him and cleaned out his closet of early eighties fucking
gay, his running shorts ever. And you somehow turned him into overalls,
you know, be wanting of women were wearing them. That be kind of hot, right?
But there was a bunch of guys wearing them to the,
they all look like they look like it looked like a jugglers convention.
It's the best way to put it. So I'm sitting there going, man,
I liked the big 10, I want to root for Wisconsin. Then every once in a while,
because it seemed to be like 80%, 75%, maybe 70,
a at the smallest Wisconsin fans. And then TCU, so you know,
who doesn't like an underdog? So I start walking towards the stadium, right?
And, uh, I'm thinking I'm gonna go for TCU. Fuck this. I helped this little,
uh, mountain west, whatever fucking I didn't know conference it from, Huh,
I hope these guys win. And, uh,
I start going up to the stadium and, uh,
one of my buddies elbows me and he turned around and he points to these TCU fans
and this guy is wearing brown loafers,
these light purple, uh,
like corduroy dockers with the TCU emblem and then like a v Neck sweater
and like these ray bond, fucking risky business sunglasses on.
And He, I like if you,
if you were casting a movie, do you guys see Facebook,
that Facebook social network? Do you know how like the Harvard guys,
where this is what this guy looked like? And I was like, oh my God,
are you serious?
Is this guy an anomaly or is this really what TCU was all about?
My buddy literally goes to me, he goes, that's it. I'm rooting for Wisconsin.
You know, I look at this fucking guy and I, and I was sitting there going,
you know what? I think he's right. Nah, maybe it's just, just one fucking guy.
And then I see another guy,
he has on a purple fucking blazer with gold buttons,
a white shirt, some polluted slugs and low first
to the game. And all of a sudden I started looking at these, this,
not all of them, but a good 15% of them are dressed this way,
looking like those rich kids who fucking, you know, uh, air quote,
accidentally kill their date, you know,
and then they say it was consensual because she wanted rough sex too.
And their daddy has enough fucking money to get them out of it.
That's what they started looking like. So I'm like, Holy Shit,
fuck this. I'm, I'm,
I'm rooting for Wisconsin now we're in the crush to get in the game and I look
in front of me and there's this pasty fat fuck Wisconsin fan in front of me.
What the Wisconsin had turned around and yeah,
I dunno if it was dry skin or Eczema.
He had a perfect band of it going around the back of his, you know,
his hairline at the back of his head and the flakes of it were on the back of
his sweatshirt. I know, I hope you're not eating.
Okay. So I'm looking at him gone. Oh, horrified.
Absolutely horrified. And then I'm turning around.
I'm looking at these fucking slack in a sport coat wearing douchebags and at
that point I didn't know who I was for.
I was actually hoping that during the flyover,
one of the jets would go into the crowd and they could just start all over
again. It was, it was horrific. Worst Group of fans I've seen.
And in three years,
granted I was sober this time and I could actually remember this.
So I go into the stadium, right? And, uh, Lo and behold,
I'm in the TCU section, right? And I'm like, okay,
uh, I dunno if I liked this and I just, and I'll sign it here.
Start here.
Take say, Yay, this girl like three rows back, tastes Jay.
You come on, come on frogs.
And I go, frogs. They had the fuck it. I didn't know what they were.
We've got to give it to Wisconsin. Badger is a bad ass fucking hammer. TCU Horn.
Frocks okay. And, and that their mascot, look,
I don't think it looks like something out of like the, that star wars bar scene,
you know, and again, let's go frau come on. Tasty.
You take, see you. And I'm looking at the girls and they, they,
they have their jeans tucked into their cowboy boots.
Like they're in that band, great white, you know,
and then on top they have like these dime store Dolly Parton cowboy hats on.
And I was like, oh my God, I fucking hate these people. And at that point,
and I was sitting right in the middle of them and I immediately just became a
Wisconsin Fan. Now in defense of TCU,
I think if I was hanging in the Wisconsin section, I would route,
I would have rooted for TCU. I would have ruled for TCU, you know,
in the middle of me just screaming that tacy g you come off frogs.
I can't tell if Nia just laughed or the guy downstairs yelled at me, oh,
that's a dark, oh, okay, my fault. Or it's Mel Blanc.
I'm good. Anybody imitate a dog barking better than that guy. Anyways,
let's plow ahead here. So then I just sat there and uh,
just was rooting for Wisconsin and I just wanted it and I, and I just,
another thing too that's really fucking annoying about TCU
okay,
is no matter what's going on during the game,
they have a reason to fucking put their hands in the air. See,
can't see the fucking game.
Anytime it was third down they had this gay little thing where you know you make
the a m o k sign.
They would do that signifying third down and then they would just sort of shake
their hands like you just in case you don't know what town it is and it
everybody.
So it's like third down at anybody who watches football knows third down is a
really important fucking down as a fan you played of paid a fuck load for the
ticket.
You want to see what happened and these fucking idiots are so busy going to the
loo. You couldn't see anything. Then, not to mention
this fat whore in front of me who from the size of her should have been a
Wisconsin fan, but then again I've been to Houston, Texas. Okay.
Those people like their barbecue to the,
these are the people that really make America look bad.
It's the fucking middle of the country. You got damn people.
I don't know what your problem is is because you're landlocked.
Don't they have swimming pools where you people could do a couple of laps people
on the coast or in shape. All right. Seattle. All the way down to San Diego.
These motherfuckers are in shape. Go ahead. Yeah.
San Diego grew right up to coast Los Angeles, San Francisco,
or a Portland, Oregon. They're in shape. A Seattle. They're in shape. Vancouver.
I even leave the country and they're fucking in shape.
You stopped getting out there in Nebraska, Iowa. Wisconsin.
Huh?
It's fucking, people are, are, are horrific other than Florida.
Florida doesn't count. All right. Florida is a, I don't know what it is.
It's like the ball bag, but he says, it looks like a dick to me.
It looks like a fucking 56 year old. Scroll up. Just hang in there.
I'm after the Dick got lopped off. Um, anyways, so they,
they handed out the like, like them doing that third down thing wasn't enough.
They handed out these fucking little purple like rags.
Okay. First of all, stealing from the Pittsburgh Steelers, the terrible towel.
They steal that and then on them it said fear the frog,
which they stole
from a Maryland fear the turtle, right?
The first school to actually admit that they have a bad name,
a bad mascot fucking name.
So then what they would this fucking fat whore
in front of me. I swear to God. Every God damn play.
Yeah.
Okay. Her fucking team would be,
we had ends on seats were was in the other end zone at Wisconsin's 10 yard line
trying to drive in for his score. Okay. They're there 90 yards away.
If you're standing on the goal line,
forget about being 40 50 fucking rose up in the goddamn stand.
And she would be sitting there as she's talking to a friend too.
That's what killed me. Classic, broad it again,
she's sitting there shooting the shit. You know,
she probably went there for the tournament of fucking roses and she just kept it
and I finally,
I tapped her on her fleshy shoulder
and she immediately took it as I was saying, put it down. I said,
can you just wave that? Can you wave it more in your like in front of you,
which this is the funniest thing ever.
She does and immediately realizes that when she does it,
she can't see the fucking game. Welcome to my world, you fat whore.
That's what I've been dealing with for the last three fucking quarters.
So then what she did was, is she then switched into her left hand. Okay.
Because not only is she a fat whore, she's a dumb fat whore. Okay.
In the first moment when I tapped her, she was like, oh,
this guy must be a Wisconsin fan, you know,
because he's telling me to put it down. Then she realizes, oh, it's in his way.
Then she waves it in front of her face and realizes, oh, now I can't see,
and you would think at that point light would dawn on our fucking fat head and
she'd be like, oh, I get it. If I waved this thing,
people behind me can't see the fucking game. Not this fat whore, not this one.
She fucking puts it in the left hand and starts waving like that.
Like that's the solution. Like she notice that
there's another fucking 80,000 fans to her fucking lift up. It was the worst.
And it's times like those where I just a
times like those were made for taster's choice.
You remember that coffee just brew up a Nice Hot Pot and you just dump it right
over her fucking head. That's what I would've liked in a perfect world.
And as she screamed from the scalding Burns,
um, she would collapse afterwards and maybe pass out either way,
she would be out of my way. And I got to tell you,
that would be the equivalent of three normal Americans who live on the coasts,
who live near the ocean. Hey, you know what?
I just realized that's how I'm gonna make my million dollars,
my multimillion dollars. So I compare a shoot out of this God damn business.
I've been trying to come up with, um,
some bullshit that I could sell for 1995 late at night. And I think I just did,
you know, I'm going to sell,
I'm going to sell a ocean water and little salt shakers for 1995.
That's what I'm going to do. And I'm just going to go, you know,
have you ever noticed how, you know,
people who live on the coast of this country or in shape, you know,
and now and now just show a bunch of good looking people running down the street
with their knees nice and high, like the Wisconsin fuckin marching band,
which was the shit, um,
just running down the fucking street, you know, high stepping it,
and then the white version of high stepping,
which is basically wring our knees up to our waist as opposed to the Grambling
black version where you basically, you know, you're,
you couldn't do it in a dome stadium because you would break your fucking toes.
Okay.
Whenever black people were trying what try it anyways.
So, uh, yeah, I would, I would sell that and I would just say,
and then you get, and if, you know,
are you tired of being fat in the middle of the country?
And just so somebody has sent a bun,
taking a bite out of it and then just looking at the camera like, you know,
throwing their arms up like, Ooh, yeah, I am sick of being a fat fuck. You know,
you know they have cinnabuns on the east coast. Why are on the West Coast?
Why aren't they fat fox? And I'll just, I just spin it.
It's because they live near the ocean and they're smelling that salt water in
the air. And I just make up a bunch of shit.
I'll pay off some fucking people in the FDA.
It doesn't seem like a hard thing to do,
considering half the drugs that get approved nowadays,
and I'll just say it's because of smelling salt water,
air that you're able to eat Cinnabon and shut off those fucking pounds.
And I'll sell it like little bottles of fucking colognes,
every fatty in the fucking Midwest and I'll make my money.
And then I'm going to move to Denmark and I'm going to pay 90% taxes yet have
free health insurance and a, you know, when a little vesper,
I'm going to go around those little fucking a
little streets out there. I'm trying to put together a Scandinavian tour.
By the way, this year. I'm really looking forward to that. Um, so there you go.
You know something like you, I also lost interest halfway through that.
So that was the rose bowl for me this year. I didn't drink. I had a,
uh, I had a fucking awesome time. I remember the game. Congratulations to tasty.
Let's go froward. Congratulations to you.
A horribly horribly dressed human beings just horribly dressed.
Trash, white trash is the only way to describe what I saw out there.
You guys really looked like you never left the Greater Dallas area.
Um, you know,
I'm going to go out on a limb here and I would say I'm never going to get an
opportunity to perform at that school.
And if I ever get an offer, I'm going to be really suspect of it,
thinking that they actually listened to this podcast. Oh my God,
the dime store fucking oh, every the woman,
women are dressed like the, that Dolly part movie,
best little whorehouse in Texas, except they were serious.
They probably put on my best hat for the s one.
I saw a guy actually took a picture of them or did they zoom into them?
I have some video, I've got to give it to my web guy. Um, of this guy.
He was dressed in a suit with a big black Stetson looking like fucking a j r
Ewing standing. You know, if it was the early eighties out,
well he would've looked good, you know, but it's fucking 2011, dude,
it's time to let that go.
You're fucking oil man slash coke dealer.
Look from fucking 1981 30 years later, you're still rocking.
That look like dead serious, dead serious.
These are the kinds of people that think like theirs. You can cure homosexuals,
you know, and uh, you know, like when those countries,
singers like need a hit, so they just write a song about how great America is.
And they're too,
and the fans are too dumb to see through the fact that they're just trying to
make money. Maybe it wasn't visible. Play the too far away.
[inaudible] [inaudible]
make me strong enough to wash away the dishwater this said was
lemonade after the show.
[inaudible].